This video is brought to you by Warby Parker.
What's up wisecrack Michael here,
and I am back to pudding in my doctorate in philosophy to the most honorable of
uses,
analyzing the philosophical merit of fictional debates in popular television.
And for this one, we need to visit the Athens of the mid Atlantic,
the gathering place of poets and scholars alike.
Patty's pub you probably know how much we love.
It's always sunny in Philadelphia,
but you might be wondering if you missed the episode featuring a rigorous
philosophical debate. Well,
the philosopher in question is one Ronald McDonald and the lecture we're
considering is this careful deconstruction of the theory of evolution.
Because evolution doesn't exist. Of course.
I'm sorry. And before you call me at your Brony, well,
let me persuade you in today's video.
A philosopher reacts to it's always sunny in Philadelphia,
but before we continue, I want to give a quick shout out to this week's sponsor.
Warby Parker,
Warby Parker is committed to providing exceptional vision care online and in
stores offering eyeglasses sunglasses, eye exams, and contact lenses,
TLDR,
they offer really stylish glasses and make it super easy to purchase a pair.
Hassle-free their glasses start at $95, and that includes prescription lenses.
Along with your regular old pair of glasses,
you can get sunglasses Progressive's and even blue light lenses.
The best part is that they offer a free home try-on program.
So you can check out the fit from the comfort of your own home.
All you have to do is take the quiz, which is really easy. I promise.
And it'll suggest pairs for you to try on simply add it to your cart.
And then you get a nifty box with five frames shipped right to your house.
Then you can try on all your different glasses with different outfits,
with makeup or whatever you need to do to make the best decision.
After all picking out glasses is a big decision.
So then she'll probably have them for a while. Then when you're done,
you just send them back and choose your favorite check out.
Warby Parker is free home triumph program today. There's no obligation to buy.
So check it out. It ships free and includes a prepaid return shipping label.
Try five pairs of glasses@homeforfreebygoingtowarbyparker.com slash
wisecrack.
Now back to the show in case you haven't seen this episode in a minute,
here's a quick refresher. Frank rear ends Dennis's beloved rain drover,
which causes him to spill the bowl of cereal. He was eating while driving,
because how else would you eat cereal?
But somehow in their efforts to seek justice things, go off the rails.
Reid mental institution here by decrees Frank Reynolds to not have
donkey brains.
Then evolution comes up and Catholic Mac puts together a poster board
presentation on why science is a liar sometimes. And in the process,
he inadvertently gets into two super interesting and contentious philosophical
topics.
The reliability of scientific knowledge and the debate between faith and reason.
Let's get into it.
Now, this is all about making myself credible in your eyes again,
and I'm going to do that by admitting that evolution is a
lot, as you can see, this is the evolution meter,
and I've put God the creator of everything on the right side and evolution
on the left.
Lots to talk about, uh, sadly, won't get into Mac's lovely shirt, but I,
I love what he does right here.
So by putting evolution on the left and religion on the right. Yeah,
you get it. Basically. It seems like Mac is pointing out what you already know.
It's certain forms of conservative.
American Christianity are quote unquote anti-science and there's precedent for
that, with what the church murdering heretics for hundreds of years in all.
But this divide isn't inevitable. After a few well-intentioned thinkers,
uh, took one for the team.
The enlightenment brought on a whole new era in which scientific thought was not
only allowed, but encouraged.
It was like emo kids used to be picked on in high school,
but then all of a sudden it went mainstream and sad looking dudes and tight
pants became the new jocks.
But this new era of science didn't leave religion behind. In fact,
many enlightenment philosophers found no contradiction between God and
rationality with Descartes thinking.
God was still the foundation of all our knowledge and con constructing a system
that left room for faith.
But clearly Mack didn't learn about this at Catholic school because he's setting
up a pretty clear either or paradigm. Let's keep going.
Stand here, present some egg heads,
scientific argument based on fact, I'm just a regular dude.
I like to drink beer. You know, I love my family rock flag in Eagle, right?
Charlie, he's got a point.
I won't change my mind on anything regardless of the facts that are set out
before me, I'm dug in and I'll never change.
Okay, let's dig in. Then this gets at an important distinction.
One Mack says he won't change his mind no matter what,
he's not describing faith. As most religious galleries would define it.
He's describing fanaticism, a fanaticism,
which is usually defined as obsessive zeal and uncritical enthusiasm as a type
of blind faith. In which those who don't agree with you,
aren't simply different. They're just wrong or worst actively.
Your enemies fanaticism is like faith that got real drunk and decided that
everyone in the bar wanted to start some it's not good.
And historically fanaticism functions as a politicized version of faith,
which leads to stuff like the crusades, colonialism,
which trials and Kirk Cameron's film career,
all of which are crimes against humanity, German philosopher,
Emmanuel Kahn noted the important distinction between faith and fanaticism for
him. A person can have faith and still exercise reason,
but fanaticism is a blatant misuse of reason.
So basically once you enter the land of fanaticism reason is out the window
and bad things are probably going to happen. So, um,
let's watch some bad things happen.
Not going to get us to not believe in evolution. And why is that?
Because the smartest in the entire world all agree that it's.
Okay. So, um, Dennis right here is touching on an uncomfortable truth.
Many of us believe in things like evolution,
because some authority figure told us to, as a result,
a lot of people claim that science is in itself, another kind of religion. So,
um, let's see how this plays out.
Science is a liar. Sometimes
this is Aristotle thought to be the smartest man on the
planet. He believed that the earth was the center of the union.
Okay. So, so yeah, it's true. He did.
He also thought that eels grew out of mud and well,
Aristotle might've been a bad astronomer with very little understanding of the
dynamics of ELL sex.
He also used his free time to create the intellectual foundations for
philosophy, theology, ethics, natural science,
and mathematics for hundreds of years to come. Um,
but I'm sure max is, he's about to say that right now.
I'm sure let's watch him do it.
Until another smartest guy came around Galileo and he just proved
that theory making Aristotle and everybody else on earth look like a.
Okay. Um, yes, it's true.
He momentarily kind of holds like a, but again,
he kind of also invented natural science. So, uh,
you win some and you lose some, um, let's see where Mac takes us next.
Galileo, then thought comments weren't optical illusion.
And there's no way that the moon could cause the ocean's tides.
He was also wrong making him and everyone else on earth.
Look like a again.
Okay. Um, honestly, I can't stop thinking about max shirt.
So anyone watching this, if you know where he got that shirt, um, or, you know,
put it up on email, I'll buy it from me for a lot of money, but, but again,
okay. So the guy Galileo was trying his best with the tools he had. Also,
he helped prove that the earth revolves around the sun.
So not bad for some dumb science. Okay. Up. Let's keep going.
Sir. Isaac Newton gets born and blows. Everybody's nips off with his big brains.
Of course,
he also thought he could turn metal into gold and diet eating mercury,
making him yet another stupid fish.
And you have to respect his, his conviction there. Um,
but as Ronald has explained,
one way to look at massive shifts in scientific understanding is to say that
anytime someone comes up with new ideas,
they make previous scientists look like.
But instead of seeing this as a bad thing,
we might reframe it as a good feature of science, a philosopher of science,
Thomas Kuhn called these moments of scientific humiliation paradigm shifts,
rather than looking at human knowledge as one consistent process of fine tuning.
thought that every now and then knowledge takes a massive and revolutionary leap
forward. That undoes a lot of what came before and, you know,
makes everyone look like fidgets. For example, for a long time,
smart science is thought disease was spread by bad air. And that as a result,
fresh air could treat things like tuberculosis or influenza,
but then people like Robert Koch and Louis Pasteur made some paradigm shifting
discoveries. For example,
that tiny microscopic church called germs were giving us life ending diarrhea,
but not everything about the old theory was wrong. Uh, the bad air stuff,
AKA miasma theory,
who was actually right about some things specifically that poorly ventilated,
dirty and crowded spaces tended to spread disease.
A fact confirmed by germ theory from their germ theory would go on to
also explain all kinds of other new mysteries that my asthma theory couldn't
like, uh,
why boiling milk is a good idea because these paradigm shifts create new types
of understanding.
A thought that different paradigms necessitated making those before you look
like. Those, those are a hundred percent his words, which he absolutely said.
For example, once you discover that the earth isn't the center of the universe,
previous astronomy is basically useless. And as you can imagine,
those from the previous era might feel pretty as their life's work is now
obsolete. And this is why max plank,
a German physicist said that a new scientific truth does not triumph
by convincing its opponents and making them see the light.
But rather because its opponents eventually die and they new generation grows
up that is familiar with it. Or in max terms, if you try to make me look like a,
you're going to have to prove me wrong over my cold dead body. Okay.
Uh, that got dark. Um, let's, let's get back to patties.
Mr. Reynolds. These were all the smartest scientists on the planet.
Only problem is they kept being wrong sometimes.
Ooh, that's sometimes it's doing a lot of work. Uh,
but this is still kind of interesting because whether you're Mac or Thomas Kuhn,
you might ask why trust these people who are always inevitably wrong,
but it's more complicated than that.
We might consider how every paradigm seeks to understand a phenomenon,
but also to make predictions.
And so miasma theory could predict the good ventilation and clean air would stop
the spread of disease. And it was right in that respect even before then,
the reigning paradigm was created by Hippocrates.
We thought that in imbalance of humor's constant illness and according to his
observations, it could explain some things like why,
when one humor phlegm showed up in the throat, people would start coughing.
It's not that a pocket was doing good science,
but even his flawed theory had a certain ability to explain human health before
further investigation poke holes in that paradigm. Well,
the point is historically paradigms are useful and also make people look
dumb when more useful paradigm show up. So for philosophers of science,
the existence of paradigm shifts is a good thing because it shows that science
isn't a Holy dogmatic or fanatic enterprise. Also that it's a type of knowledge.
That's able to disprove its all assumptions and accept new truths.
If scientists weren't able to acknowledge that they were wrong sometimes or in
max terms, if science wasn't a discipline,
then we would still believe that bleeding out could help with the flu or that
semen from the right testicle creates male babies and semen from the left
testicle creates girl babies, which sounds like something Charlie would say,
but it's actually something the Roman thinker Pliny, the elder thought.
But of course, as everyone knows,
you have a boy baby of right before you have yogurt with sprinkles on it.
And you have a girl baby, right before you finish,
you say that's a spicy meatball, but everyone already knows that.
So let's get back to Mac.
Well, because I have more faith in the saints that wrote the Bible. Yeah.
Because you just read the words of a bunch of guys that you never met and you
just take it on faith that everything they wrote was true.
Okay. So, um, remember the difference between faith and fanaticism? Yeah.
That's what's happening here. Um, this isn't genuine faith.
This is reckless belief without the possibility of seeing otherwise as former
glass bubble car enthusiast, Pope John Paul,
the second said faith without reason leads to superstition, which once again,
forces us to ask what did Mack actually learn at Catholic
school? Um, maybe tell us in a second.
Do you think what your scientists are writing is any more truer than my saints?
Because there are volumes of proven data numbers, you know,
figures. There are fossil records. Okay. Uh.
Let's see if this is any more truer. Um, so,
so what's the difference between max saints and Dennis's data
numbers and figures. It's pretty simple.
While the saints might have some pretty useful mythology and stories that can
help you live a good life. It's not scientific data.
It's like comparing your wise grandma who told you to never look an Irishman in
the eyes to genetic research. One is pretty messed up folk wisdom.
And the other is grounded in observable evidence.
But what if you haven't seen that empirical evidence for yourself?
Part of why belief in science is a little different from belief in religion is
that science is a different institution with different values.
The scientific community has norms of peer review of reproducing experiments to
make sure the other person didn't make mistakes or even straight up lie.
And that results are consistent over time.
But what about dinosaurs? Let's see what that.
Oh, fossil records. Ah, I didn't even think about the fossil records,
I guess I'll concede. Oh wait, one more thing before I do Mr. Reynolds,
have you seen these fossil records? Okay. Um, now.
I might not personally go look for dinosaur bones,
but I can trust that if someone tried to pass off some glued together chicken
parts as a dinosaur, somebody else in the field would catch it.
It's also worth noting that this isn't a perfect system free of bias,
but it's got a few more safeguards than pastor bill said,
dinosaur bones are the remains of the demons who tempt you to have premarital
sex at church camp.
You don't have to obscene fossils to know that a stegosaurus existed any more
than you need to dig up.
Abraham Lincoln's bones to know that he was tall science like history
is built upon the consensus and collective knowledge of intellectual
communities.
So it's not a matter of simply having faith that dinosaurs really existed.
Rather.
It's about having some trust in the traditions of natural science to accurately
communicate peer reviewed, verified findings and data. Um,
and I'm sure like max is going to be convinced. So, so we're fine.
Huh? Have you poured through the data yourself? The numbers, the figures.
The numbers and the figures. Okay. Um, once again,
this just doesn't matter. Um, I, I don't have a degree in aviation,
but that doesn't mean planes don't fly.
Also have you're pigging between paying for degree in philosophy and aviation
for the love of God study aviation,
but that's neither here nor there. So let's get back to our friends.
Well, no, no. Oh, interesting. So let me get this straight,
Mr. Reynolds,
you get your information from a book written by men you've never met and you
take their words as truth based on a willingness to believe a desire to accept a
leap of faith.
Dare I say it faith.
I don't know about you, but, uh, Frank and Charlie looked pretty convinced.
See what's happening here? Is it.
Mac has reverted to his either or paradigm about faith and reason,
but a centuries worth of philosophers maintained faith and reason can co-exist
without breaking your brain. Uh, actually, unless you're Charlie,
in which case your brain will most definitely overheat. Um,
let's see what they say next.
Come on, look. I mean, I don't even know how I'm supposed to respond to that.
Like that is,
that's a false equivalency. Just answer the question, Mr. Reynolds.
Sure. Yeah. Okay.
Mac broke Dennis, I think. Um, and,
and this is where Dennis gets himself into trouble because scientific knowledge,
isn't a matter of faith. It's grounded.
Like I said earlier in institutions and fields of research that have their own
internal systems of criticism and verification that require evidence.
And by not understanding why science is different than religious faith,
he's ended up looking like a stupid science. Okay. Uh,
we're almost there. Let's see how they wrap this whole thing up.
I rest my case. Well that got me
on the fence. I mean, it's a shadow.
You actually don't believe in evolution anymore. I don't know.
He created reasonable doubt. He makes you sound like a stupid science.
Okay. And there it is. Uh, but more seriously,
the real irony of max lecture is that the whole faith versus reason debate
was largely settled. Heres and years ago, uh,
philosophers from Aquinas to Descartes, to Conda, Hegel, to Kierkegaard,
didn't see a contradiction between religious belief and rational knowledge and
help even the Catholic church in the current Pope,
don't see any contradiction between their theological beliefs in the theory of
evolution or the big bang theory. So why is max so upset?
This force contradiction between faith and reason,
isn't really a philosophical problem,
but a political one rather than delving into an interesting philosophical
problem. Mack is merely parroting a culture war.
His fanaticism is seemingly an attempt to return religion back to the pre
enlightenment days of burning heretics and converting via the sword a time,
which was to use the technical term, not chill,
careful philosophical reflection on both science and religion make both stronger
and more intellectually rigorous. As the old saying goes faith,
without reason is blind and science without philosophy is Neal the rest Tyson's
Twitter feed. So in conclusion,
Matt brings up some important questions to which he offers some fairly
ridiculous solutions. And Dennis might technically be more writer than Mac,
but he falls into the trap of treating science like its own religion.
But most importantly,
and the thing I really want you to take away from this video is that even though
it's stupid to eat cereal while driving it's absolutely Frank's fault and he
should provide satisfaction.
But what do you guys think is Mac actually pointing out some fundamental issues
in the philosophy of science?
Does Dennis have more in common with Neil deGrasse Tyson than one might think
and is D actually a bird, let us know in the comments.
We'd also love to hear about other shows, movies or sex Colts.
You'd like me to give a philosophical reaction,
to be sure to hit that subscribe button, like your rear ending.
You're not real sun and ring that bell. Like it's last call it patties.
And as always, thanks for watching later.
[Inaudible].